la madrugada este lunes se firmó en
Montreal el marco global para la
biodiversidad en el que 196 países se
comprometieron con 23 metas para frenar
el deterioro de los ecosistemas del
planeta de aquí al final de la década el
histórico acuerdo que se logra tras
cuatro años de negociaciones establece
el 30 por 30 la protección del 30% de la
superficie terrestres y acuáticas del
planeta de aquí hasta el año 2030 una
meta que sería equiparable al uno punto
cinco grados del acuerdo de París en
materia de cambio climático este acuerdo
también Establece que se reduzcan los
subsidios dañinos a la naturaleza en
hasta 500 mil millones de dólares al año
y la reducción a la mitad en los
desechos alimentarios y también en los
efectos nocivos de los pesticidas para
financiar estas metas se estableció la
creación de un fondo de 200 mil millones
de dólares al año provenientes de
fuentes públicas privadas nacionales e
internacionales así como también la
creación de un flujo financiero hacia
los países en vías de desarrollo de unos
30 mil millones de dólares al año la
República democrática del Congo no
estuvo de acuerdo con la aprobación de
este marco y reclamó que los recursos
que se le ofrecían a los países en vías
de desarrollo eran insuficientes para lo
ambicioso de las metas sin embargo este
comentario fue tomado como un reclamo
informal y no como una objeción formal
por lo que el acuerdo fue Igualmente
aprobado las ong ambientalistas piden
que los gobiernos comiencen a crear
planes nacionales y que los presenten
antes de la cop16 que se celebrará en
Turquía en 2024